i'm here at sidekick central and i'm
pretty much gonna buy almost every
single thing that they have that's
relating to marvel in the store to give
away to you guys let's go
[Music]
hello hi i didn't know we were filming
what's up guys it's warren welcome back
to cosmic wonder we are in
this beautiful
beautiful place sidekick central as you
can see here they have so much marvel
stuff and i'm here to essentially buy
all of it so we can give it away on all
of our channels instagram twitter
facebook whatever we can give away we're
gonna try to give away here as you can
see there's just a ton of stuff we know
you all love these
and for this christmas with hanukkah for
whatever you're celebrating even if
you're not celebrating anything we're
gonna be doing a massive giveaway uh
with all this so everything you see here
basically we're gonna buy and we're
gonna be giving away
and we're also gonna be playing some
cool games with some people in the store
as well a lot of stuff here
this is going to be an awesome gift back
to you guys as you can see the store is
awesome that is kelly the owner down
there she's a little bit camera shy but
she's super super awesome
we've been working together she's great
okay so we've already bought a lot as
you can see but a lot of people are
actually starting to come in and it's a
saturday um i'm gonna have to actually
clean up the entire store for the marvel
section so
yeah we'll see about that i might have
to just mr beast it like i bought the
entire marvel section of the store which
i'm very glad to do to give away to
people so if you want to enter this
giveaway there's going to be a few
different ways but basically if you're
watching this video right now
whatever you're watching it on whether
it's youtube whether it's my cosmic
wonder youtube cosmic culture youtube
marvelman news if you're watching on
twitter if you're watching it on
facebook if you're watching it on
instagram on my personal one or on the
cosmic wonder one wherever you're
watching this video comment down below
your favorite superhero that's how
you're gonna be entered i will comment
back to you if you win this is gonna go
till the end of the year i'm gonna be
giving away all this and it looks like
more so
so wherever you're watching this video
right now comment down below your
favorite superhero and if you get a
comment back from me
you win good luck all right so we're
gonna grab some stuff to give away to
you guys let's go ahead and just go
through this entire wall and see what
they have right here so right off the
bat we have some egg attack obviously
the heads there i know a lot of people
like some of these so we're gonna go
ahead
and take a look at both of these stores
and let's go ahead and grab some i think
people are gonna like these so you know
what
oh yeah these are cool these are really
really cool let's go ahead this shelf is
going to be
what we're getting right here so we'll
start we'll start right here we have to
get the others to work obviously we have
to get the other thor you know let's
grab a couple let's grab a couple right
here so we'll stack them up like this
and this will be this will be our shelf
right here all right we got a couple
floors and obviously we have to get iron
man this is from avengers infinity war
this is still one of the egg attacks one
but it's pretty cool they got a lot of
cool you know you can put the mask on it
you can put a different helmet on it
half damage like this is pretty cool we
definitely gonna have to get one of
these
okay
got some egg attacks here but these
check these out these are actually
really cool these are prop rings
from the movie that they wear the rings
that wanda and vision wear well that's
really cool okay there's only a couple
left of these so i mean we obviously
have to grab these right all right we
are here
yeah i mean obviously we have to we have
to grab a gambit magneto's a huge one
magnet is one of my personal favorite
villains of all time if you want to calm
the villain
anti-hero anti-villain at some point in
times but yeah i mean obviously you have
to grab your food all right i think some
people like miles morales i'm not too
sure about that obviously of course
everybody loves miles morales
and these guys
all right we're gonna have to buy
i know everybody loves miles morales so
we're gonna have to buy a ton of these
let's go ahead and put these over here
all right these guard next to thanos
cool so far very very cool this is the
one of a kind i know everyone's going to
really want this guy right here this is
going to be one that people are going to
have to fight over we're going to have
to figure out a special way to give this
away because i know everyone's going to
want this including myself you're going
to have to fight me for it but we'll put
it over here and the stuff that we're
gonna buy today all right so we
originally planned on just walking into
the store and buying a bunch of marvel
stuff but as some people came in and
started to realize what we were doing
and as we met a lot of fans i thought it
would be pretty cool to do some
giveaways in the store so we did and we
asked them just pretty basic easy
questions about marvel we weren't trying
to make them hard we wanted them to be
easy so they could win and walk away
with something from the store and be
happy and it was really a fantastic
experience and there were some truly
great and touching moments with some
dedicated fans in this store but first
let's get through me buying almost every
single marvel item in this store but
stick around for some truly awesome
moments
this is a pretty cool one as you can see
right there still egg attack can replace
the head
so we'll grab a captain marvel here put
her on the shelf all right we're moving
into some really cool stuff now
the hall of armor iron man hall of armor
these are going to be cool
got it boom
we'll do this
there you are we'll have to get more of
those too obviously
[Music]
we can't just do one and we'll have to
do
two because they're four to complete the
set
good how are we looking
good so far
good so
okay
these we gave away and people loved so i
know we have to buy
basically
all of these right here these are the
variant bring arts we gave away that
spider-man here's an iron man one you
have a captain america and a thor
these are all insanely cool i just
obviously gotta get them all
well
four right here we have four of these
four more i know people love these
there's four more chances here
and we'll put them right next to the
other spidey
all right but we obviously have to get
the other ones too we'll do
four ironmans as people know like as far
as marvel goes four is one of my
favorite characters as far as mcu goes
he is my favorite character wolverine's
my all-time favorite character but you
know
let's go ahead and grab some stories
and i mean we'll just complete it with
captain america of course right when we
we have to
well
saved it and that is really cool that is
super super cool
these i really like
these have always been personal
favorites of mine
so i'm really excited to give it away
all right captain you sit on top of
these guys right there we're definitely
getting one of each in the store no
matter what let's grab a couple of these
let's grab a couple of these
so let's grab a couple please a couple
of these and this dark exchange is
fantastic we have to grab one of these
guys as well so
bringing them over
pretty decent amount of stuff so far but
i think the next one people are gonna
really really enjoy here now this is a
hot toy so it's super super nice and
this is a collectible
and i know so many people are going to
want this hot toys miles morales from
the ps5
game we have one
that we're going to be getting this is
going to be a very very special gift for
yourself for someone you love
but it's a collectible so you have to
treat this right whoever wins this
has to treat this right or callie's
gonna come and take it back from you
because she truly loves we are out of uh
we're at a room new show new show and
we're not done let's keep going he's
cool guys
really cool venom we have spider ham i
know venom is super hot right now
everybody's loving venom since we're
coming off of venom let there be carnage
and that post credit scene no spoilers
but looks like we're going to be seeing
a lot more venom so let's go ahead and
just grab some of these guys spider
spider-ham's over here
we're bringing them over here all right
oh that's where we're going next don't
worry
one of my personal favorites spider gwen
and look who we got here i know people
love this stuff and then we already got
spider ham so i mean obviously i just
all right kyle hit me put those on top
for me
no these this yeah
breaker is going to be included in this
so for those of you who have been
wanting a stormbreaker
we're gonna get this guy right here so
oh no
so if you want this
i have one of these at home
it's amazing
it's like fantastic and it's it's heavy
it's very
it's very sturdy and real i'm not gonna
break anything so i'm gonna put it down
well you know what i know we have
some star wars fans and they have a
really big selection of star wars stuff
including these right here which i love
the new stormtrooper helmets and check
this out
these are so cool
that when you put them on they actually
make the voice
of the stormtroopers they change you
these are not the droids we're looking
for
we gotta get through these right i mean
clearly
vader obviously right we can't just get
storm trooper and not get vader i'm too
short to grab those but they have some
over
i here we obviously can't forget about
star wars fans how can you not do star
wars you can't do star wars not have
fader
so let's do this
right out of here
but this is good because it's all going
to you all so
i'm gonna buy it now yeah
all right
that's it
okay your total is 5191.49
just so you guys know i actually bought
this
all right we have our first one here our
first
contestant for a giveaway this is
brayden some more potential giveaway
winners here we have zoe so we have here
paige and we have megan we're here with
henry so daniel's our next contestant
we're going to ask you a couple super
super hard questions and if you get them
right
you're going home with this did you
watch adventures
we did we did
what did iron man say to his daughter
in avengers in game what's the last
thing that his hologram said to her
i love you three hours okay we have a
winner who's your favorite superhero um
wonder woman wonder woman is a good
answer we're still in the running right
now okay
what is
iron man's
real name
all right all right we got it don't
worry she knew it the whole time she
knew what the hole to get pressure there
were
the members of the fantastic floor
who are they
okay
mr fantastic yeah we have two can you
give the next two yes uh the invisible
woman
and
uh the human hearts okay bonus
who's related
he would torture me
okay cool marvel dc or star wars which
is your favorite star wars are you gonna
see the new spider-man movie when it
comes out okay
what is your favorite marvel movie
um black panther i've seen i saw like
three times in the movie oh my god cool
cool cool name the original avengers
from the first movie can't save hawkeye
yeah black widow yeah thor yes iron man
captain america
did i say black widow
thor hawkeye
captain america oh there's gold there
you go captain america shield and
bucky's arm are made of
this happens all the time i know you
would you be surprised so vibranium yes
exactly so like people know these
answers but when they're put on the spot
they forget them callie the storm is
about to get this guy his name is jamie
he walks in here every single day
looking at all the stuff in here but
doesn't necessarily have enough money to
buy
some of the stuff like a lightsaber so
i'm gonna give him a lightsaber or a
helmet or something that he wants
because i mean for someone who comes in
here every single day and can't get
something he deserves to have something
so let's let's do it i i heard you come
in the store like every day awesome yeah
i'm a mall rat okay
i need to get a
certificate of like a world of finger
[ __ ]
well it's a it's a thing of having a
part-time job seeing like i'm disabled i
have autism
trying hard to find a full-time job and
make a living but
well i have a part-time job i'm just
basically bored and
um
before my dad passed away he was very
sick and he was on ssi so he could not
have a job and
to kill time and find entertainment he
would bring me and my older brother to
tomorrow we walk around and he says i
can't find much just window shots so
i got walking around the mall
for my father when it's on
i come here almost every day go to south
tomorrow almost every day
i've been to the mall so much i've made
friends that's awesome well you know
what my father passed away two not too
long ago and he took me to movies all
the time and talked to me and that's how
i got into all this stuff as well too
but callie tells me that you love star
wars i do
you're such a big fan you come in every
day i'm going to go ahead and get you
and you want a lightsaber
oh my gosh kick something out whatever
you want you're spoiling me man
you never forget
oh my gosh don't spoil me too much i
might get carried away
i'm about to pass out right now oh it's
okay it's my pleasure to do that you
deserve it you're a big fan oh my gosh
thank you we have jackson here who
claims to be a hardcore marvel fans
we're gonna test his knowledge on this
we're gonna answer some questions so i
have uncle milk that dr strange has on
him
what infinity stone
i didn't even have to finish the
question he already did okay what is the
name of tony stark's a.i
do you know the next one friday
this is good all right this this will be
the final one to win the prize
what part
in
honor of how knowledgeable jackson is go
ahead and pick out whatever you want
[Music]
that's yeah you want that yes that's
what we're going with right here yep
no
all right i'm glad this is going to an
actual fan of all the pop culture stuff
the mandalorian with the baby yoda that
comes with it all right jackson there
you go buddy
hopefully you get a cool one in there
all right man you got it let's go get
the shredder
what does captain america say
right before all of the heroes of
avengers in-game go to battle thanos's
army adventures assemble
all right
okay we have new giveaway winners here
go ahead and pick out what you want grab
it
thank you all right
we have a second winner it's perfect
all right
high five
thank you thanks guys see ya
kick ass page make it whatever you
and we really did all right thank you so
much no problem megan oh right right no
yes
perfect
yeah i'm really glad you came in today
that's so perfect yeah nice job hanging
out here is your mace windu um have a
great day man a good holiday and thank
you so much for uh for hanging out with
us thank you okay high five
sweet we're gonna go ahead and let you
pick out anything that you want here
from the store there so go ahead just
pick whatever you want there
do you want a stormtrooper helmet
he gets a stormtrooper helmet thank you
no problem
dude that is so cool all right henry
thanks for stopping by today we'll see
you give away stuff for these two guys
right here guys go ahead and pick
whatever you want
oh um
everything
well
for thor
all right we i i knew someone was gonna
take storm breaker we'll have to get
another one to give away to you guys but
here we go
so yeah
this is a really cool one
thank you very
much congratulations and thanks for
watching
take care
all right since you answered all the
questions right he's a big batman fan
we're going to go ahead and give you
this awesome batman for you today here
you go buddy
now as i mentioned if you want to enter
for a chance to win some of these items
that i bought in the store well there's
good news because there's a lot of ways
to enter i'll be giving these away on my
youtube channel the cosmic wonder on
cosmic culture and on marvel minute news
as well as on my twitter and my
instagram both personal and the cosmic
wonder instagram i'll link every account
that i'm doing a giveaway on in the
description and pin comment down below
comment on this video on whatever
channel it's on or if it's on my social
medias comment on my post and i'll be
picking random winners for an
opportunity to claim one of these prizes
and it will be first come first serve
basis so best of luck to everybody hope
you enjoyed this video and this was
really for you all i wanted to give back
to you all you've done so much for me
and i greatly greatly appreciate all the
support that you've given me so far and
i hope we have many many years ahead of
us together so i love you all three
thousand and thank you so much for
watching
[Music]